SAURABH GUPTA: Welcome to Don't
Hate, Automate using
Google Apps Script.
My name is Saurabh Gupta.
I work in Google Developer
relations with Apps and Cloud
Developer relations team.
This is our QR code for
giving us feedback.
So please get it.
And we will get it when we start
the QA sessions as well.
So if you love Google Apps, if
you use Google Apps, and you
want to get more out of Google
Apps, then this is the right
session for you.
If you want to be more
productive using Google Apps,
if you want to extend how you
use Google Apps, like how you
use Calendar, Contacts, Sites,
Spreadsheet, then Google Apps
Script is what you
need to use.
Today I'm going to talk about
what is Google Apps Script,
and more importantly, why
you should use it.
And what are the different
types of use cases around
Google Apps?
And I'm going to touch a little
bit about what are the
various services that are
available in Apps Script and
how you can use them.
And I'm going to go over a demo
application, and then
tell you how you
can get started
using Google Apps Script.
And I'm also going to talk a
little bit about I/O sessions
for tomorrow and day after.
So by show of hands, how many
of you have heard of Google
Apps Script?
And how many of you
have used it?
Quite a few.
Interesting, OK.
So what is Google Apps Script?
Google Apps Script
is a JavaScript
engine in the cloud.
That's the technical
definition.
But it's another way of saying
you open up the browser, you
write some code, and that code
gets executed in Google
servers and you get
the response back.
But more interestingly,
what it is that
Google Apps Script does.
So Google Apps Script lets
you access Google
APIs in an easy way.
So if you want to access your
calendar and automate some
task using your calendar, you
want to access your email, or
you want to access some data in
your spreadsheet, then you
can do that using Google
Apps Script.
You can also integrate with
third party APIs, like
Twitter, Netflix, other
APIs that are
available out on the web.
And Google Apps Script makes
it easy for you to do that.
Apps Script, as I said,
is a JavaScript
engine in the cloud.
So naturally the JavaScript
syntax is easy to use.
And we have made it
even simpler for
users to use Apps Script.
And I'm going to show you in the
demo how easy it is to use
Apps Script.
So JavaScript, syntax, and
classes are available to you.
On top of that, we provide a
wide range of Apps Script
services, which make the Apps
Script a lot more meaningful
and useful.
So if you wanted today go out of
the session and say, OK, I
figured out a use case as to why
I want to use Apps Script,
that's enhancing and extending
your use of Google Apps.
That's you automating
a few of your tasks.
But the more important question
is why you want to
use Apps Script?
So I'll share a personal
story with you.
So I have family in
three continents.
And we have a family calendar
where we have all sorts of
birthdays, anniversaries,
everything.
And we have reminders set
up a few months ago.
And three days in advance
of anybody's birthday or
anniversary, an email
comes out.
It's like Google Calendar
reminder alert--
somebody's birthday
is coming up.
And the email automatically
goes into archive.
And we forget about
the person's
birthday and all that.
So my dad calls up and says,
you work for Google, right?
Can't you figure out a system
where on the day of the event
itself, a nice email goes out
to the person whose birthday
it is, and then the joke
of the day or whatever.
And then that starts a whole
interesting conversation in
three continents.
I said, yeah, we can do that.
Absolutely.
We have Calendar APIs,
Gmail APIs.
We can write a neat app.
I can do that.
I can deploy that app
in App Engine.
I can put in a scheduler.
That app will run every day
for 40 people across three
continents.
So I thought, well,
we can do that.
But I won't do it.
It's just too much work.
And it's not worth it.
It's not worth my time.
So there is automation
right there.
But the use case
is too narrow.
It's not worth my time.
But, well, with Apps Script, you
could do that very easily.
In 20 lines of code, without
having to deploy anything,
without having to write any
code, you can do that.
That's automation right there.
Then there are other scenarios
where Apps Script is useful in
terms of automation.
Say you want to produce
a sales report
every Friday night.
And the sales figures are
in the spreadsheet.
And you want to perform some
logic in the spreadsheet, get
your spread data from
spreadsheets, and then prepare
a report and have it emailed
to whoever you
want to email it to.
You can do all that
stuff manually.
But with the Apps Script,
you can automate it.
Not only can you automate it,
but you can actually set up
triggers such that it gets
executed at a particular time
of the day, or the week,
or month, or whatever.
So that's automation.
So our goal is to make you use
Google Apps in a way which is
more meaningful for you.
You can automate it.
You can be more productive.
So in the story I just shared
with you, one of the key
things in the story was that
it was an interesting use
case, but it wasn't worth my
time implementing a full-blown
app deploying on
the App Engine.
Well, with Apps Script, it
certainly is, because it's a
very small script, it's
implementing a very fringe use
case, which has light volume,
but it's still feature-rich.
It still requires all
those access to
APIs, things like that.
And if there is some breakdown,
some change or
something, then I need to get
to it very faster now.
And I need to access my Calendar
data, my Spreadsheet
data, along with some joke of
the day site, some RSS feed
somewhere, which is a third
party API, or whatever.
So I can do all of that and
implement that very narrow use
case for my purpose.
Now, how is that
useful to you?
Well, if you are in an
organization that is using
Google Apps, or if you are using
Google Apps for personal
use, then you can still
implement a lot of these
different types of use cases.
For instance, say there
is a law firm.
And there's, like,
10, 15 people.
And you want everybody
to book time.
You're going to have a
very small lab which
has some UI in it.
Users book time.
And the data goes into
a spreadsheet.
And you can generate reports,
things like that.
It's a very narrow use case.
But you can implement it very
easily using Apps Script.
So the third most interesting
reason why you want to use
Apps Script is because
it's cost effective.
Now, I don't mean in terms
of dollars and cents.
But when I say cost effective, I
mean in terms of how easy it
is for you to implement, manage,
and maintain this
[? stuff. ?]
So with Apps Script, you don't
have to do any software
deployments.
You don't have to deploy
a software.
You don't have to take a big
JAR, ZIP, [? TAR, ?]
RPM, and deploy it
on a machine.
You don't have to
do any of that.
You don't have to elevate
machines or capacity.
And you don't have to worry
about any hardware allocation,
anything like that.
So those are the two
big benefits,
right out of the bat.
Obviously these benefits derive
from the fact that it's
a JavaScript engine
in the cloud.
You open the browser.
You write some code.
That codes get executed.
And so no software deployments,
no hardware
deployments.
But then the other very
interesting benefit of Apps
Script is that it is part
of Google Apps suite.
So what it gives you is it gives
you a context in which a
script runs.
And that context is loaded with
a Google Apps, a Google
account identity.
And now that's very important,
because if you're writing a
standalone app, which uses
Calendar, a GData API, and
then you're deploying in App
Engine, then you have to worry
about URLs.
You have to worry about
authentication, authorization,
all of that.
But not in Apps Script.
In Apps Script, when you write
an app, and that app users
Calendar services, for example,
to access your
calendar or some other calendar
that you have access
to, then authentication is
already taken care of.
Because the app is running
under your
Google account identity.
So that's a very big benefit.
That's cost savings right there,
because the barrier to
entry to using APIs
is very low now.
You can access your contacts,
your calendars, your
spreadsheets, your sites, and a
wide variety of other APIs.
And I'm going to show you
in an example what other
different types of APIs.
So who should use Apps Script?
So our goal in the Apps
Script team is
that anyone can script.
We want to make it so simple
that anyone should be able to
open a browser and bold enough
to write a script.
It's not just us hardware
developers, but that's heavy
business users, educators,
teachers who want to make a
classroom experience more
effective, students who want
to even learn programming.
It's a great way to do that.
So Apps Script is for users
across a wide range of
spectrum, from tech-savvy
business users, to hardware
developers, to educators, to
students, to other types of
business users.
And we want to make it so
simple, and our goal is that
anyone should be
able to script.
So how does someone
use Apps Script.
And I'm going to show
you in a demo.
But if you concentrate on
the right-hand side
of the diagram here--
when an author writes a script,
then the user can
access that script through
a Google Sites page.
So an author can write a script
and embed the script in
a Google Sites page.
And all of a sudden, your Google
site becomes alive,
because you can do a lot more
with Apps Script and make your
site's experience
a lot dynamic.
You can do the same thing
for spreadsheets.
So you can embed script
in spreadsheet, access
spreadsheet data, or make
spreadsheet objects clickable,
things like that.
So scripts are exposed through
spreadsheets as well.
Not only that, you can
[? export ?] scripts as
standalone web applications.
So you can write a script that
does whatever, and then you
can publish it with a URL.
And anyone who has access or
that you grant permission to
access can invoke that URL, and
then all of a sudden, in a
standalone way, they're
accessing your script.
And the fourth way, how scripts
are used is through
asynchronous triggers, where
the script could be
time-driven.
There's no specific user
action to invoke those
scripts, but it's sort of
a trigger mechanism.
So what are different types
of Apps Script services?
So up until now, what we covered
is why you want to use
Apps Scripts.
You want to be productive.
You want to automate a lot of
the user Google Apps tools.
And you want to implement a
wide variety of use cases.
Like just yesterday evening
at our [? GTEC ?]
conference, there were so many
ideas that we've figured out
we can implement using Apps
Script, like accessing
Calendar and syncing Calendar,
things like that.
And the third reason was,
it's cost effective.
But how do you do that?
So these are some of the
variety of services.
But before I start describing
these services, I'm going to
show you a quick little
demo as to what Apps
Script can do for you.
So I'm going to go into
a Google site which
I have set up here.
So this is a site.
It has a whole bunch of
different Apps Scripts.
But I'm going to focus on one
particular Apps Script, which
I call the training script.
So this script is sort of a
simulation of our training
scheduling app.
So this is for-- say, imagine
an organization which has,
say, 100 people or 50 people.
And it wants to offer
training.
And it signed up for
a Netflix account.
And Netflix has great training
content available.
So it wants to let its own
members, organization members,
employees, or school, or
whoever, to search for Netflix
titles, and then add those
titles to a spreadsheet in a
queue, and then schedule
a training
in a training calendar.
So that's what this app
is going to do.
And this is one script which is
embedded in a Sites page.
And what I'm going to show you
is how a site's experience
comes alive.
So I'm going to click
on Training here.
And all of a sudden, the
script gets invoked.
So this is sort of a two step,
three step workflow.
As a member of this
organization, I'm asked, OK,
choose a training category.
So there are different
categories.
And these are all part
of the script.
Now, Script has many
types of services.
So it's using UI services.
So say, for instance, I want
to learn a new language.
So the script now pulls
all the data.
This is just one Apps Script.
It is pulling data from
Netflix's OData API, getting
information on titles that
correspond to a certain genre,
which is training, or learning
a new language, or
something like that.
And then it's able to
show those titles.
Not only that, you would
have noticed that it is
interactive.
It is not like one way, where
a script is able to just
generate some random HTML.
It actually was able to take
some action when I selected a
certain genre as to what
I want to learn.
So the script can actually
write full-blown UI
application.
And I'm going to show you how
easy it is to write these
types of UI applications.
So let's go back to the
language instruction.
And say I want to learn a new
language, and say I'm in the
mood for learning Italian.
So I can click on
Add to Queue.
So by clicking that, what
I'm doing is I'm
selecting this title.
And the information of the title
goes into a spreadsheet,
which is a queue.
So when I click on Add to Queue,
then that's the next
step in the workflow.
And it asks me, OK, what is
the training date that you
want to schedule the
training on?
So I'll just give a
random date here.
So let's say 11.
And I'll say, OK, I want to
choose an 11:00 AM slot.
And I'll say Schedule
Training.
So as soon as I click on
Schedule Training--
click on it.
Let me select it.
Demo gods.
OK.
Oh, there you go.
Finally, we were successful.
So by selecting a time and
scheduling training, now the
script actually created an event
on the training calendar
based on the selection
that I did.
So let's see what it did.
So let's go to the calendar.
And let's reload it.
Demo gods.
The calendar is--
there you go.
So I have an event scheduled
at 11:00.
So this is the basic
power of script.
It now is able to enhance
your site's experience.
And all of a sudden, your Google
Site becomes home for a
lot of different types of
office productivity, of
workflow, and other types of
applications which are
important, expensive to
implement on very narrow use
cases or maybe mainstream use
cases, but still expensive to
implement and do not have
enough volume that it
justifies a full-blown
development.
So let's go back to our services
here and discuss a
little bit about what types of
services Apps Script has.
So the first category of
services that Apps Script has
are called the content
services.
So that's the top-most block
right there, with Spreadsheet,
Sites, and Docs list.
So with Spreadsheet's services,
you can access your
spreadsheets data using Apps
Script and then perform any
meaningful logic in it and
do a lot more with it.
Not only that, you can write
custom functions and embed
those in a spreadsheet.
So it's [? AKA ?] macro.
So you can write a macro
and then embed it in
a spreadsheet cell.
But you can also access
your site's page data.
So say, for instance, you want
to create new announcements in
Site's pages.
So if you have an announcement
type page and you want to
create an announcement, you
can very easily do that by
accessing Site's APIs.
And Docs list, for those of you
who don't know what Docs
list is, Docs list is when you
go to docs.google.com and you
see a list of all the documents
that you have in
your Docs list.
So you can manage
You can manage permissions.
You can script out
permissions.
You can maintain it.
I personally use it to
manage my Docs list.
Like, it can grow a lot larger
because so many people share
documents with you.
But you want to organize it
based on certain rule logic.
You can certainly do that.
And that script can run, say,
weekly, nightly, whatever.
But the idea here is that we
want you to be able to take
your data, sort of liberate it,
allow you to do whatever
you want to do with that data,
and then do some more.
So that's the first types
of services, which are
[? content ?] services.
And this particular code
example, this is taken right
out of this training
application, which shows you
how easy it is to use
spreadsheet services.
So in the first line here,
you see I just use
SpreadsheetApp.open.
And I get the spreadsheet key.
And then I get the sheet.
And all of a sudden, I have a
reference to a sheet here.
And then I can just get a
range in the sheet using
sheet.getRange, if you see the
third line in the code.
And then I can very easily
set values in the range.
That's how easy it is.
So not only it is easy to read
data from spreadsheet, but you
can do the same thing when
you want to write data.
And I'm going to show you an
example in the editor how easy
it is to use the editor.
Because editor is sort of a mini
ID, where it offers you
code assessed.
It offers you capabilities
where you can use these
services very easily.
So this chart shows you a little
bit about what you can
do with these different
services.
So I'm not going to go
into great detail.
So the next type of services
are messaging services.
Messaging services are
communication services where
you can now access
your contacts.
You can access your calendar.
You can send emails.
So you can very easily write
a script that accesses your
contacts and a group of contacts
or only selected
contacts, and then send them
customized emails, for example.
So that would be a very good use
case for lot of different
data-driven communication
that you may have.
For instance, you may
want to send the
example of sales report.
You may want to send it to only
certain people if the
sales numbers are low
or high or whatever.
So you can now access
your contacts.
You can access your calendar.
And you can interact more
meaningfully and in an
automated way with
people around who
are also using Apps.
So this code snippet is an
example of how easy it is use
Calendars, for example.
So you use
CalendarApp.getCalendarById,
and all of a sudden you have
access to your calendar.
How cool is that?
And then you can use standard
JavaScript date functions to
instantiate date clusters, and
you can create an event.
So for example, in our example
about sales reports--
say if the sales numbers come in
low and you want to take an
action automatically where you
want to schedule an event with
a group of people or calendar
event, then you can
certainly do that.
You don't have to manually
look at something.
You can do those kinds of things
in an automated way.
Use of Calendar API, for
instance, comes in very handy
if you are managing events.
Then let's talk a little
bit about third
party integration APIs.
So not only can you use Apps
Script to integrate with a lot
of Google Apps products--
as I just mentioned, Calendar,
Contacts, Spreadsheet, Sites,
and others--
but you can also access
third party APIs.
And in the example that you
just saw in the training
application, we used UrlFetch
APIs in Apps Script to connect
to Netflix's OData API.
Using UrlFetch, you can also
connect to APIs that require
OAuth-based authentication.
And Apps Script really makes
OAuths very simple.
So if you have a use case where,
in a site space, you
want to fetch data from an API
that requires OAuth, you can
do that very easy in one line
of code using UrlFetch.
We have SOAP APIs.
We have JDBC connectivity.
So if your database server is
available, accessible, using
JDBC from Google servers, then
you can run JDBC queries.
You can access a bunch of SOAP
APIs if the SOAP interface is
what you're using
for [? it. ?]
The overall idea is that we
want you, as Google Apps
users, to be able to extend
the way you want
to use Google Apps.
We want you to be able to
implement all the different
types of use cases that you
could using Apps Script.
So this is a code snippet which
shows you how easy it is
to fetch data.
And this is the exact cut and
paste from the training
application that I
just showed you.
So we form a URL here, which is
from Netflix's OData APIs,
and then we form a full-blown
request.
And we just say UrlFetch,
UrlFetchApp.fetch, and we then
parse the [? result. ?]
It's that simple.
And if I were to use, say,
Twitter's API, which required
OAuth, it wouldn't be any
longer than that.
It would be probably four lines,
just like what this is.
So the fourth major category
of Apps Script
services are UI services.
And they are actually
quite interesting.
So using UI services in Apps
Script, you can create very
functional, meaningful,
good-looking UI applications,
as you just saw in the
training application.
So the underlying implementation
of UI services
is Google Web Toolkit, without
all its complexity.
So using Apps Script, you can
use UI services to write UI
using JavaScript without
having to worry about
compiling your Java code, and if
you were to use Google Web
Toolkit without having to worry
about a lot of different
complexity that comes
with deploying Web
Apps, things like that.
Using UI services, you can
very easily assemble UI
components, all the widgets that
are available, deploy it
in a Sites page, or a standalone
application, for
that matter, and you'll
be all set.
And I am going to show you in a
little bit as to how you can
do that with one particular
example.
So this is an actual cut and
paste from the training
application, where it shows
you how easy it is to
create a list box.
And I'm going to show you how
to create a list box.
So let me copy this code.
And in an actual live session,
I'm going to show you in Live
Editor how easy it is.
You can see this all right.
So let me copy this code.
Copy the code.
So if you want to create a
script in a Sites page, then
you click on More Actions
in a Google site.
And then you click
on Manage Site.
As soon as you click on Manage
Site, you will see Apps
Scripts here on the
extreme left.
You click on Apps Script.
And then you will see a list
of scripts that you have
available in that Google site.
So here we want to write a new
script just to show you how
you can use Apps Script.
So we launch the editor and
we write our script.
So I've just copied some code.
So before I do that, each script
that is embedded inside
needs to be called doGet because
of [? get ?] call.
Then I will say I want to
start a new application.
So I'll say UiApp.
And you can see the content
assisting the editor, so how
easy it is for you to
write a script.
So I clear the new
application.
Then I will paste the code.
So I want to create a list box
label, which actually shows
labels saying choose
the category.
So I say app.createLabel here,
and I set some text.
So I don't have a decorate
function.
And I don't want to decorate
right now, so
I'll just remove it.
Then I will create a list box.
CategoryListBox =
app.createListBox here.
So it's that easy to
create a list box.
And I set a name and an ID.
This comes in handy when you're
implementing callback handlers.
For example, if I'm selecting a
particular list item, and I
want to have a backend action
on it, then it becomes easy.
And I add items to
this list box.
So now I have a label
and a list box.
But I need to add them to
my application, right?
First, I will add this
label, for instance.
And then I will say app.add, and
then I will add the list
box itself.
Now I could make it
a lot fancier.
I can add vertical panels,
horizontal panels, or flow
panels, things like that, the
types of panels that you are
used to in Google Web Toolkit.
You can have those types of
widgets as well if you are
developing a complex UI.
So once I have assembled
my application, I can
just return my app.
And I'm all set.
So let's save the script.
So I'll say Bootcamp Lecture
or something.
And I save the script.
So once I save the script, now
I need to make sure that I
have to embed this in a page.
So I create a new page.
And I call it Bootcamp
Session.
So once I create a new
page, I can insert
the script as a gadget.
So now I am editing a
page, a Sites page.
I click on Insert on
the extreme left.
And you can see Apps
Script Gadget here.
You click on Apps
Script Gadget.
Oops, did I go Picasa here?
OK, Insert Apps Script Gadget.
And you will see a list of
scripts that are available.
So here's our Bootcamp
Lecture script.
So we select it.
And now we can provide as to
who can access this script.
So I can ACL it in
the way I want.
So I said let only myself
execute it, for instance.
And I can get the height and
the title and all that.
So I'm not going to tinker
around with that.
So all of a sudden, what I've
done is I've embedded a script
in a Sites page.
Now this script could
do anything.
It could access any of APIs--
Calendar, Contacts, Sites.
It could be a workflow.
It could be an expense report.
It could be a time booking
application.
It could be any of
these things.
And it could be a UI application
which leads you
through certain workflow.
But now, because you are Google
Apps users and you have
a site, you have a place
to point to to those
applications.
So it gives you a structure.
It enhances the Sites
capability.
It allows you to use various
Google services, Apps, API's,
in a much easier way.
So let's save this.
So once I save it, you can see
the script got executed
because I am on that page.
And I've just implemented
the list box here.
And the list box doesn't do
anything because we have not
put in handlers here.
So what are handlers?
Let's go back to our
presentation real quick here.
OK.
So as you can see in this code
in the last few lines, you can
associate events with
each UI object.
So in the case of a
list box, you can
associate a change event.
And you can provide the
name of the function.
And this is the name of the
function here, which needs to
be executed when somebody
selects a
list item, for instance.
This is very similar to what
types of handlers that are
available in Google
Web Toolkit.
But this is a lot simpler
because you don't have to
worry about some of the
additional complexity.
So as soon as you give the
name of the function that
needs to be executed, and a user
selects a list item, then
you have set up a very
dynamic list box.
So there are different types
of server handlers.
There are click handlers, change
handlers, selection
handlers, things like that.
You can create a very rich
UI using UI services.
So let me talk a little
bit about triggers
and what they are.
So triggers are an asynchronous
way of executing
Apps Script.
You can think of triggers as
cron's cousin, sort of.
So there are two types
of triggers.
There's a time driven trigger,
which allows a script to
execute at a certain frequency
in a time-driven fashion.
And then there are
event triggers.
Event triggers are triggers when
a user performs a certain
action, a script got executed.
For instance, you can set up a
trigger on your spreadsheet.
For instance, when, say, a user
opens a spreadsheet, you
can have a script executed in
an asynchronous way without
the user actually, who opened
the script, who opens the
spreadsheet, not knowing or not
getting impacted by it.
So there are certain types of
event-driven triggers, which
are very useful in certain
use cases.
The time-driven trigger, as I
said, is cron's cousin, where
you can set up frequencies
at which you want
to execute the script.
So how do we make it easy for
you to write scripts?
So I'll go back to the
script editor.
And in the script editor, you
will see some ID, like
similarities.
And this is all, by the
way, a browser.
So you will see we have
a debugger here.
So you can set a break point.
And then you can run the
script in a debugger.
So it's very easy for you
to debug scripts.
You can also add
collaborators.
You can share scripts.
So you click on Share.
So you can add collaborators
to your scripts.
So two people or three people
can write the same script.
You can publish this script
as a service.
So what this means is that you
are publishing this app as a
standalone service.
So when you click on Publish
as a Service, then
it gives you a URL.
And you can distribute
this URL.
And this script can be executed
outside of sites or
spreadsheets.
So using UI services, and
publishing that app that uses
UI services as a standalone
service, you can write web app
really, really fast.
It's probably one of
the fastest ways
to write a web app.
You don't have to worry about
any deployments or all of the
stuff that we talked about.
It's like just reuse the UI
services, write a UI.
And then publish it
as a service.
And you are all set with
a standalone web app.
And then you can also
publish your script.
Like, you can share it
with other users.
And when you click on Publish
Script, you actually can
publish a script in a gallery.
And we have a gallery of scripts
where our community
has contributed hundreds of
scripts across different types
of use cases.
So it's a great way to get
started using Apps Script, is
you go to the gallery, you look
at the script or the use
case that you want to solve,
and then you go to that
particular category and then
start writing the script.
And you can publish
scripts as well.
You can manage your triggers.
I just mentioned, which is you
can click on all your triggers
and you can see if you
have any triggers.
And then you can even have
notifications on triggers.
So for instance, in my example
about the family birthday
email thing--
say, for instance, I set up a
trigger, and that trigger
starts failing.
I would receive notifications.
So I can avoid that
uncomfortable scenario that
somebody did not get their
birthday email or
something like that.
So how can you get started
using Apps Script?
So Apps Script is very easy.
You can just go to that go to
Spreadsheet or Sites and open
the browser or start
writing code.
But if you prefer a little bit
structured approach, then you
can go to our documentation
site.
And it has a wide variety of
references, tutorials, which
walk you through actual
use cases.
You can also participate in our
forums community, which is
very, very active.
And it's a great place
to share ideas.
And I just mentioned, you can
use Gallery to get started.
Say you are looking for a mail
merge solution, for instance.
You can go to our gallery and
look for mail merge scripts
that are out there that
our users have shared.
And that could be one starting
point for you.
And then you can look at a wide
variety of case studies
that we publish from time to
time as to how our users are
using Apps Script.
So you can follow our Apps
Script blog or Google Apps
Developers blog.
And you will find very
interesting case studies on
how to use Apps Script.
And I'm going to walk you
a little bit about our
documentation.
So you go to Google Apps
Script Documentation.
And you can access
all the docs.
And this is a healthy reference
that we have, of a
wide variety of services.
And this list is growing.
But not only that, we have a
whole bunch of tutorials for
beginners, intermediate,
and advanced use cases.
And then if you click on
Support, then you can access
our forums and issue trackers.
And you can see how active
our community is.
So our tutorials are a
really great way to
start using Apps Script.
I am also going to plug
our I/O sessions.
So tomorrow between 3:45 and
4:45, you should definitely be
in room two to see what's new
with Apps Script, and what
different types of use cases
you can implement, and what
more we are doing to make
this Apps Script
experience a lot better.
And then there's another session
on May 11th at 1:45,
again in room two.
You want to be there in this
session, because in this
session we are going to cover
specifically about enterprise
workflows, and how you can
implement those workflows
using Apps Script.
And this is going to be a
wonderful session because
you're going to see a wide
variety of ways Apps Script
can be used to create common
workflow applications.
So with that, I'm going to
take a few questions.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Say you wanted to have
two scripts on one page--
how do you deal with global
name space clashes?
SAURABH GUPTA: So I don't think
we are supporting two
scripts in one page
at this time.
There might be some
issues with that.
So this is a very interesting
use case.
Never come across it.
I don't think we are supporting
at this time.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Two quick questions.
The first is, so one limitation
I've found with the
Google Spreadsheets is that
you can't do macros.
Like, I like to program macros
to do grand tasks for me.
It seems like this is a
great way to do that.
But the problem being that
once I'm in Google
Spreadsheets editing my data,
I can't just press Control,
custom P, Control
X, or something
and execute my macro.
But can you make an editable
spreadsheet on a Google site
using this which also
can run macros--
as you're entering data,
you can run macros?
It seems like this is a way
around the problem of not
having macros on Google
Spreadsheets maybe.
SAURABH GUPTA: So let me
rephrase the question.
So you want to write an Apps
Script which is similar to a
spreadsheet, but gets embedded
in a Sites page?
AUDIENCE: Right, which allows
you to quickly do
modifications on the data.
SAURABH GUPTA: Right.
So you can implement sort
of a spreadsheet
using an editable grid.
But it wouldn't be a full-blown
spreadsheet that
you are used to, with all your
formulas and everything else.
So there might be some
short-changing of experience
in terms of what you will
get as a spreadsheet.
But there is certainly grid-like
controls out there
in UI surfaces that
you can use.
AUDIENCE: OK.
And the other quick question
is, I know there are other
ways to do this.
And maybe I have a question
because I haven't used Google
Checkout much.
But can this interface
with Google Checkout?
Can I put a Google Checkout
functionality on my website
that's linked through
this, and charge
people money for things?
SAURABH GUPTA: So what I didn't
talk about, because
this was [? 101-01 ?]
session, was about the
[? permissioning ?] model of
Apps Script.
So because Apps Script is sort
of a productivity tool, it is
meant for you to enhance the
overall experience of apps and
how you can extend apps.
So there are certain
restrictions in terms of
security model of how
a script executes.
So, for instance, if you write
a script and embed it in a
Sites page, then went out and
say you distribute the link to
the Sites page to all the users
in your Apps domain, for
instance, then whenever a user
hits that link, the script
executes as you under your
identity, right?
AUDIENCE: Right.
SAURABH GUPTA: So there might
be identity restrictions and
things like that.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Cool.
AUDIENCE: I notice when you're
trying to share your script,
when you tried to create a
URL, you had two options.
I can run this script, and
everybody can run this script.
Can you make it so me and three
other people can run
this script also and
nobody else, rather
than just me and everyone?
SAURABH GUPTA: So if you are
non-Apps domain user--
like a regular consumer
user, meaning if you
have a Gmail account--
then it's you and
everyone else.
That's the choice for now.
But Apps Script is meant for
Apps domains users so that
they can get a better experience
out of Apps.
So most common scenarios are
where scripts are shared with
the users who are within
the same domain.
So that's a very common
use case.
And for instance, in an
educational institution, a
professor would share a Sites
page with a group of students,
things like that.
And all of them are in
the same Apps domain.
Yes, please.
OK.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
We are Google Enterprise
customers.
So we use Google Docs, Google
Enterprise, Sites, et cetera.
But for some of the CRM
capabilities, we use
salesforce.com.
And there are some Google things
we actually want to
implement in house for
our internal people.
One thing I wanted to ask is
the gadgets you added to a
Sites page, can we add a gadget
to an email page so
that somehow we can sign
in to salesforce.com?
And when you say create a task
on this, it will give me a pop
up, get some data from
salesforce.com, and then pulse
data back to salesforce.com?
It's a little bit
more complex.
But it's not that tough, because
I can see you can call
a REST API, which exists
for Salesforce.
We can add a gadget
which exists.
So is that possible?
SAURABH GUPTA: So if I rephrase
your question-- so
what you want is to be able to
write a script, which can be
served up in Gmail, and
this gets executed
as a gadget, right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, as
a site gadget.
SAURABH GUPTA: Right,
so stay tuned.
Yeah, yeah, so stay tuned.
Yeah.
Any other questions?
Yes, please.
AUDIENCE: Can you copy a script
[INAUDIBLE] somebody
else can [INAUDIBLE]?
SAURABH GUPTA: Yeah, you
can copy and paste.
It's all available.
You can share a script
through the gallery.
So the question is can
you copy a script.
So you can do it in
multiple ways.
And we are actually expanding on
this a little bit in coming
weeks and months.
But as of today, you can copy
a script and cut and paste.
That's basic, right?
But you can also share
it in the gallery.
So if you publish your script
to the gallery, somebody can
download that script.
And that's another sharing
mechanism.
Yes, please.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
sharing.
That would be [INAUDIBLE]
access the site.
[INAUDIBLE]
SAURABH GUPTA: Right.
AUDIENCE: OK.
And then next time [INAUDIBLE]
SAURABH GUPTA: I'm sorry?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SAURABH GUPTA: Not
at this time.
Yeah.
But that's an interesting one.
The idea of Apps Script is,
because it's a productivity
tool, so we want your Sites
experience, your Spreadsheet
experience, your Mail
experience, Calendar
experience, to be elevated.
And we want you to be able to
implement those use cases that
I just talked about.
Yes.
Yes, please.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
SAURABH GUPTA: Sure, OK.
So the question is can
I show Gallery?
So I'm doing it real
quick here.
So I'll go to the editor.
And say, for instance,
I click on file.
And I say Add Script
From Gallery.
And there you can see the wide
variety of scripts that are
available across different
types of--
so these are scripts that
users have shared.
They are, by the way, great
starting points for you to
write a script.
So if, at a time like this, at
6 o'clock, you wished you had
more hours in a day, and you
wanted to automate a few
things, start with
the gallery.
See what you did today which
could have been automated.
And maybe there's a solution
out there.
Any other questions?
If you have questions, you want
to get started, you can
post on the forum.
Community is active.
Google is out on it.
I am on it.
And we constantly look for
users to share ideas.
And if they have any problems,
we are constantly
helping them out.